we begin in the US where numbers just
released show unemployment has surged in
April the biggest in close to 90 years
tens of millions of jobs were wiped out
right across the country it's
coronavirus lockdowns fatter the economy
unemployment skyrocketed to fourteen
point seven percent it was four point
four percent in March in April twenty
point five million jobs were lost
that's the worst result since the Great
Depression which began in 1929 it far
exceeds the 2008 global recession when
8.7 million jobs were wiped out let's go
now to our White House correspondent
Kimberly halket on those numbers just
coming out of the Ursuline Kimberly
today's numbers just adding to the
bleakness of yesterday's weekly figures
right absolutely and the US president
Donald Trump giving an interview to Fox
News just now talking about those
numbers reacting about the very high
unemployment rate that was not
unexpected but certainly not good news
for this administration the US president
calling these numbers in his view
unacceptable also saying that he is
optimistic that as president he can
bring this economy back you have to
remember just eight weeks ago there was
another sort of record in the books and
that was historically low unemployment
now we have just the opposite rack new
records being set the US president
saying that he believes he can bring
back a very strong economy but what's
interesting is his timeline the US
president predicting that 2021 will be a
very strong year why is that important
well the US president is up for
re-election in 2020 hidden in that
message is the underlying request that
all Americans vote for him if they want
to see these jobs come back aside of
showing this confidence that the economy
will make up for other jobs is he
outlining how that is to be achieved
I think one of the biggest things the US
president has been arguing is that it is
necessary to reopen the economy that the
foundation of the economy in his view is
sound and strong but that's in contrast
to what many experts believe because the
reality is while these jobs were lost
in a matter of weeks it could take
months even years for these jobs to come
back now I should tell you that the u.s.
president also talked about a few other
important topics that I want to quickly
just tick off in terms of headlines the
other big story here in the United
States of course is the issue of the
Department of Justice deciding not to
prosecute Michael Flynn the president's
former national security adviser the US
president promising that he will be
releasing new details about that
investigation that of course also
enveloped his own presidency for many
many months the u.s. president under
investigation in terms of his contacts
with Russia and whether or not there was
collusion during the 2016 US campaign
and also another big headline out of the
United States that it's important to
mention is that tape about Ahmad Aubry
in Georgia this is a black man who was
hunted down while he was jogging
allegedly shot by two white armed
individuals the US president reacting
that this video very disturbing saying
that he hopes that justice will prevail
but getting back to the issue of the
economy and what really has rocked this
country in terms of COBIT 19 the US
presidents say his administration has
now been talking to Chinese officials in
the last 24 hours
very interesting that the president is
saying with regards to the origin of
this virus well they always point to
China in that lab in Wuhan the US
president now saying that he doesn't
believe that this was deliberately
spread instead he's blaming incompetence
saying I don't believe it was done on
purpose so the US president in the midst
of all that the underlying message Sammy
is that the US president as he tries to
get this economy back on track is
looking to some sort of partnership
still with China knowing that it is a
very important
partner it's important to note the US
president has not weighed in
definitively on whether or not there
will be additional tariffs as punitive
action towards China for the reality of
what he faces with this economy and
these jobless numbers in the United
States clearly alone in this play right
now thanks so much Kimberly how could